170 milliards de dollars de dommages
c'est la facture des dix catastrophes
climatiques les plus coûteuses de
l'année 2021 selon le rapport de l' ong
christiane head l'organisation qui
précise que le coût pourrait en réalité
être plus élevé car ces estimations sont
basées uniquement sur les dommages
assurés le bilan ne s'arrête donc pas là
il est avant tout humain ces dix
catastrophes ont fait plus de 1000 morts
et ont contraint à l'exil plus d'un
million trois cent mille personnes les
coûts du changement climatique ont été
élevés cette année à la fois en termes
d' impressionnante pertes financières
mais aussi en termes de décès et de
déplacements de personnes dans le monde
qu'il s'agisse de tempête et
d'inondation dans certains des pays les
plus riches du monde ou de sécheresse et
de vagues de chaleur dans certains des
plus pauvres la crise climatique a
durement frappé en 2021 le dôme de
chaleur qui s'est installée en juin au
canada et aux états unis fait partie des
plus impressionnants de ces événements
une température record de 49 6 degrés
celsius a été atteinte dans le village
canadien de lytton les inondations qui
ont frappé l'allemagne et la belgique au
mois de juillet ont entraîné la mort
d'au moins 180 personnes en allemagne et
d'au moins 35 côté belge selon le world
with her attributions ces épisodes
étaient directement liées au changement
climatique est largement prévisible on
ne peut pas dire qu'on n'a pas été
averti le giec et les scientifiques
tirent la sonnette d'alarmé depuis
tellement longtemps et sont si peu
écoutés en dépit de catastrophe de plus
en plus nombreuses et d' alertes
répétées de différentes ong rien ne
semble réellement avancer dans la lutte
contre le réchauffement climatique
cette année la coop 26 était pourtant
présenté comme un événement majeur est
cruciale pour le climat mais à la sortie
c'est un accord jugé décevant qui est
arrivé sur la table avec des engagements
qui selon les ong ne permettront pas de
maintenir le réchauffement mondial des
températures à 1,5 degré celsius